I recently sat down with presidential
candidate Tulsi Gabbard this is the full
interview if you have a short attention
span like I do you can check out the six
minute version I posted earlier this
week but the entire interview is
interesting so here it is I started on
an area where we agree endless wars she
often says she knows the cost of war so
I asked her what do you mean I'm a
soldier I've been serving the Army
National Guard now for over 16 years and
deployed twice to the Middle East I've
served in Congress now for nearly seven
years on the Foreign Affairs Committee
the Armed Services Committee in the
Homeland Security Committee and so from
both perspectives understand the
importance of our national security and
as a soldier served in a field medical
unit in Iraq in 2005 during the height
of the war our camp was about 40 miles
north of Baghdad and I mean it was
something everyday
that we all experienced firsthand the
terribly high human cost of war of our
fellow soldiers friends of ours who were
killed in combat and the cost and the
toll that continues now with with you
know veterans coming home with visible
and invisible wounds dealing with
post-traumatic stress you've said the
best way to honor our troops is to make
combat the last option we don't we we
have to honor our servicemen and women
by only sending them on missions that
are worthy of their sacrifice now you
know like so many Americans after al
Qaeda attacked us on 9/11 I made the
decision to join our military to enlist
to be able to go after and defeat those
who attacked us on that day to defeat
that great evil that visited us but
unfortunately since that time our
leaders failed us where instead of
focusing one pointedly on defeating al
Qaeda
they've instead used that attack on 9/11
to begin to wage a whole series of
counterproductive regime change wars
overthrowing authoritarian dictators in
other countries
Wars that have proven to be very costly
to our servicemembers the American
people Saddam Hussein Gaddafi and the
ongoing regime change war that's still
happening in Syria today so in
Afghanistan you would have gotten out
when go in defeat al-qaeda get out
that's what should have happened instead
what we're seeing now is a very long
protracted and big ewis mission where no
one really knows what quote-unquote
winning looks like and the ensuing
nation-building that's followed in these
different wars that's taken so much of
our resources our taxpayer dollars out
of where they should have been dedicated
and nation-building and serving the
needs of our people right here at home
if we just pulled out there would be
more slaughter probably if we stay
focused on our mission and what our
mission and objective should be which is
the safety and security of the American
people then we end up saving a whole lot
of lives we end up saving a whole lot of
taxpayer dollars the conflict and the
complexities and the challenges for
example in Afghanistan that we're seeing
continuing over the years and through
today are things that only the Afghan
people can resolve but we've got to stay
focused on is how we ensure the safety
and security of the American people
there's seldom is a discussion that I've
heard about what is our mission exactly
that's exactly the problem is is before
sending our men and women into harm's
way we're not hearing about okay what is
the problem that we're trying to solve
and what is the clear achievable goal
that we need to accomplish that we're
sending them to do and and without that
we end up with the result that we have
where we have troops who are deployed in
these other countries without a real
understanding of what they're there to
accomplish and at what point they then
accomplish that and then can come home
let me get your response to this op-ed
in The New York Times from some years
back about Syria five reasons to
intervene in Syria now it would diminish
Iran's influence in the Arab world let's
look at what's happened in Syria
because of the regime change war that
we've waged there because of the regime
change war that we waged in Iraq Iran
has far more influence in both of those
countries than they did prior to our
going in this is exactly one of the
problems where we see how our regime
change wars and intervention has been
counterproductive to our own interests
the argument was this could keep the
conflict from spreading to Lebanon and
Iraq yeah once again we look at the cost
and the consequence that both the Syrian
people have paid as a price and the
impact that it's had on the region as a
whole we can see how these decisions in
Iraq Libya and Syria have been counter
to our national security interests and
something that these articles often fail
to recognize or or announce which is
that al-qaeda has been strengthened
terrorist groups like Al Qaeda and
offshoots like Isis have been
strengthened as a result of these
policies and these Wars to the point
where now we just observe the 18th
anniversary of the attack on 9/11 and Al
Qaeda is stronger today than they were
in 2001 when they launched that attack
stronger because when you kill their
cousins and brothers more people hate us
stronger because our leaders failed us
by not staying focused one pointedly on
defeating al Qaeda and instead went and
spent American lives and resources in
waging these regime change wars and
seeing how terrorist groups like Isis
were born because of those wars in Syria
right now al Qaeda and other terrorist
organizations that are offshoots and
affiliates are in control of this entire
city of idlib in the northern part of
Syria and you know other countries are
Syria and Russia in particular talking
about attacking al Qaeda getting rid of
al Qaeda in that city and it is
President Trump and his administration
that are the ones saying don't go after
al Qaeda in that city and if you do will
retaliate against you for doing so this
is a total betrayal it's a betrayal of
every single one of us as service
members every single family member of
those who were lost on 9/11 to the first
responders who ran into that rubble and
that fire to save lives that day rather
than running away it's a betrayal to us
as the American people but there is a
human rights crisis there and our hearts
go out to them what we want to help we
want to help what we have been doing has
been making the problem worse this is
what is so often the case when when
these these regime change wars are waged
in the guise of humanitarianism saying
exactly that that there are people
suffering under a brutal dictator
authoritarian regime we have to go in
and help them by removing that dictator
but if you look at these examples
throughout our country's history our
going in toppling that brutal dictator
has not made their lives any better they
have resulted in more death more
destruction more pain and suffering more
refugees this is why we've got to stop
being the world's police and recognize
that if we want to be a force for good
in the world let's actually make sure
that what we are doing affects in a good
outcome you met with the dictator with
Assad yes and the liberal media give you
grief for that I would think that they
would say we should talk to everybody
better talk and wage war I agree you
would think that's what they would say
Chris Cuomo you need to acknowledge that
Assad is a murderous despot are you
surprised
and then what I think this is the
problem is you know we look back to
examples like a Roosevelt meeting with
Stalin another murderous leader you look
at JFK meeting with Khrushchev Nixon
meeting with Mao there are examples
throughout our country's history of lead
Reagan meeting with Gorbachev leaders
who recognize that in the interest of
peace and security you have to be
willing to meet with leaders of other
countries whether they be adversaries
friends dictators or otherwise
recognizing what you just said that the
only alternative to that is war
so what's going on with your party
Democrats used to be the anti-war party
unfortunately this is something that
crosses both parties and I call out
leaders in my own party and leaders in
the Republican Party as well who are
heavily influenced by the
military-industrial complex that profits
heavily off of us continuing to wage
these counterproductive wars they're
heavily influenced by a foreign policy
establishment in Washington whose whole
power base is built around continuing
this status quo so much so to the point
where when I'm calling for an end to
these wasteful Wars they're saying well
gosh Dulce why are you such an
isolationist as though the only way that
we can relate with other countries in
the world is by bombing them or putting
crippling economic sanctions in place
which is a really sad conclusion when
you actually the sad state of mind
rather than seeing hey we're the United
States of America we have the
opportunity to be a force for good to to
reach out to other countries to work
with them to show respect to find those
areas of common interests where we can
work together for the well-being of our
people and the planet and be able to
work out those differences that we have
rather than resorting to war
seeing that war is only a last resort to
keep our people safe if you were
president a few years back what would
the alternative have been with Syria how
would we have worked with them well
first of all making sure that we don't
launch a regime change war that war
began a lot of people don't realize in
2011 all the way back in 2011 and it
began with a covert mission working
through the CIA to both arm and equip
and provide support to terrorist groups
in that country like al-qaeda to
overthrow the Syrian government this is
something that has now been you know
published out in the open that this is
what happened and it continued to
further escalate both through covert and
over it means using the Department of
Defense so if you were president you
would come in and say this has poisoned
our relationship we're gonna stop this
and here's what we are gonna do what we
do is respect
the rights of the Syrian people to
determine their own governance and their
future this was one thing that night
their dictator they hold elections in
Syria
some people questioned the validity of
those elections so one thing that I
think the international community can do
is come together to provide global
oversight over those elections to make
sure that the people's voices are
actually being heard now we have the
conflict with Iran they just apparently
were responsible for the attacks on
Saudi Arabia what would you do if I were
president today I would end this cycle
of retaliation this tit for tat that
we're seeing what happened in Saudi
Arabia was an act of retaliation to the
sanctions and the blockade against Iran
and basically stopping them from being
able to sell any of their oil on the
market remove the same I would get Iran
and the United States to re-enter the
Iran nuclear agreement to make sure that
Iran is not continuing to move forward
in building a nuclear weapon get those
inspectors back in there and I would
remove those crippling sanctions I'm
gonna quote Lindsey Graham a weak
response invites more aggression this is
the problem with people like Lindsey
Graham is they advocate for things like
punish we've got to punish Iran for this
punishment is not a goal or objective
the question is how does that how does
that help us accomplish our objective
because since the wall street journal
they sense weakness if we are strong
they'll behave so if we are strong and
we do what Lindsey Graham says and we
come in with a strong response and a
counter-attack to Iran a retaliatory
attack how does then Iran respond these
are the questions that these policy
makers in the media too often don't ask
well what does Iran then do Iran say
well Iran knows we mean business and
they'll behave better and when has that
happened if Iran is given no sign so
Iran has given no signs of surrender
they have stated very clearly their
military is ready to go to war
and that they will withstand any
counter-attacks that we have this is
this is not a joke I mean Iran is a much
larger country than Iraq military is
much stronger many more people and they
they use both conventional and
unconventional warfare tactics so if we
follow down the Lindsey Graham approach
what we end up with is a continuation
and an escalation of this tit-for-tat
retaliation attack counter-attack
counter-attack and what we will result
in what a resultant is an all-out
inferno not only in Iran but across the
entire region it's it's unimaginable to
think about how many American lives how
many servicemen and women would lose
their lives in such a war how many
people in the region would be killed
refugees forced to flee and how many
more trillions of our taxpayer dollars
would be taken out of our pockets out of
our communities to go and pay for a war
that is completely unnecessary and that
actually undermines our national
security let's move to a domestic area
where you agree with us libertarians
America locks up an unusual number of
people two million at the moment more
than Russia China our criminal justice
system is so broken and it's
perpetuating the problems that have
caused this kind of mass incarceration
that we've seen I have the only
bipartisan bill in Congress that would
end the federal marijuana prohibition
this is one easy first step that we can
take to begin to end this failed war on
drugs that has unnecessarily filled our
prisons and that has really been a drain
on our resources both from the law
enforcement perspective as well as
within our criminal justice system
people say it's a gateway drug and the
country has to send the message to
children that it's not okay you're gonna
let it be legal everywhere we should
this is this is a free country I've
never smoked marijuana I never will
I've never
drank alcohol I've chosen not to in my
life this is about free choice and if
somebody wants to do that our country
should not be making a criminal out of
them for doing so and I think this is
the whole hypocrisy of this argument
that we've heard throughout our lives
since this war on drugs has begun which
is we really care about you we really
care about your kids so if you are
caught using this drug or smoking
marijuana we care so much about you that
we're gonna arrest you and we're gonna
give you a criminal record because we
care about you and we don't want you to
hurt yourself a record that will follow
this person for the rest of their lives
and impact their ability to you know get
a job or maybe get a college scholarship
something like that
so once for an adult we own our own
bodies and we ought to be able to poison
them if we want yes what you haven't
proposed legalizing heroin or cocaine or
meth that's the direction that we need
to take is decriminalizing an
individual's choice to use whatever
substances that are there while still
criminalizing those who are traffickers
and dealers of these drugs but I'm
confused by that because if you say and
I agree that it's my body let people do
what they want yeah but you call the
sellers traffickers it's sold their only
traffickers because it's illegal isn't
that hypocritical you can use it but
nobody can sell it to you yeah no it's
not at all I think there's a difference
here where you have those who are
profiting off of selling substances that
are harmful to others as opposed to
those who are making those choices on
their own to do what they wish with
their bodies there are some models of
this in other countries who have taken
this approach and what we've seen in yes
in Portugal what we've seen in Portugal
is how they are not treating a drug use
as a criminal action but instead as a
health care one that for those who are
dealing with substance abuse and
addiction that rather than throwing them
in prison and and giving them a criminal
record we're actually providing them
with help and and the healthcare
treatment that will get them and their
lives back on track and that's been good
in Portugal there are even it's out well
fewer people using the drugs
that's one reason that's exactly right
talking about this at the debate you
changed
Kamala Harris's life look I was raising
I think very valid questions about a
record that Kamala Harris herself has
said she's very proud of as California's
Attorney General and around an issue
that I think is central and important to
all of us for the reasons that we just
talked about it speaks to the broader
issue of leadership which i think is
really what's that question here for all
the voters who were asking to earn their
trust in their vote so that we can serve
them as presidents what kind of leader
would you be and asking those questions
of Senator Harris about the kind of
leadership that she provided when she
was in a position of power to actually
help fix our criminal justice system
instead she used that position to
further perpetuate a system that was
causing disproportionate harm to to
people of California her job was
prosecutors so she's supposed to
prosecute that's true but as a
prosecutor and as as a presidential
candidate she's talking about fixing
this broken system she was in a position
of power to do that to make sure that
those she was prosecuting were people
who were deserving of that prosecution
deserving of that prison time but
instead of enacting those reforms that
would have actually helped people she
chose to do the opposite and I think
that just again points to leadership and
the failure of it she was leading in the
bedding for Democratic nominee
immediately she fills seven points ten
days later another seven points from 26
percent to 12 percent
you killed her off I'm for the people
man I was speaking the truth and and and
speaking for a lot of people a lot of
people who were
asking these questions who were calling
for accountability and we're seeing not
seeing none in the mainstream media
seeing none of the debate moderators
asking these questions as they should
have every candidate saying hey here's
your record how do you account for that
that hadn't happened prior to that
moment which I think is is a disservice
to voters so now the clear leader is
Elizabeth Warren are you happy with that
obviously would rather you yeah
no I'm focused on on our campaign and
how we can connect continue to connect
with voters in the early states and all
across the country and sharing with them
the kind of leadership that I would
bring the experience that I bring to
serving as president and fulfilling that
most important responsibility the
president has is as commander-in-chief
your campaign pitch has been instead of
all this military spending focus on
rebuilding communities at home that's
right meaning meaning there are so many
needs that we have that our families
have that the American people have and
for so long and I've served that in the
City Council in Hawaii served as a state
representative and obviously in Congress
now for seven years and for for so long
people are told well you know there's
just not enough money to make sure that
you know your kids have the the most
up-to-date textbooks in your classrooms
there's just not enough money to upgrade
our water infrastructure to make sure
that the water coming out of your tap is
clean and is not poisoning or harming
your kids or your families there's just
not enough money to make sure that our
roads and bridges are safe for people to
use that are not dangerous and posing a
threat to your families every single
time the American taxpayer is told sorry
there's just not enough money but
they're told this by some of the very
same people who don't think twice who
don't ask well how do you pay for this
when they make the decision to go and
launch again these wars of choice they
are unnecessary they are
counterproductive and they are regime
change wars that work against our
interest what to speak of the fact that
now we are in a new Cold War we have
escalating tensions between the United
States nuclear-armed countries like
Russia and China a new arms race Trump
tore up that INF treaty that Reagan and
Gorbachev negotiated sparking off
billions more dollars to build these
missiles that were banned under that
treaty all of this amounts to an
incredible cost that whether they
realize it or not every single one of us
as taxpayers are paying where those
dollars should either be used to
decrease the deficit that we have or to
serve the needs of our people and what
do you mean when you say focus on
rebuilding our communities at home that
implies that they were doing okay and
then now they need to be rebuilt
did something happen that made them
worse the City Council district that I
represented in Hawaii was one of the
first communities that was developed
when people started moving to Hawaii and
the population started growing which
means the infrastructure in that
district was the oldest on the whole
island that constantly needed upgrading
and for so long it's just you know we'll
put a bandaid on this we'll put a patch
on that but really that doesn't solve
the problem of the fact that we would
have water mains that are underground
constantly breaking exploding and
basically creating a sinkhole and the
main roads that people go to school and
go to work in every single day it's
these kinds of challenges that our folks
in Hawaii are experiencing but
challenges that people are experiencing
in many communities across the country
so how did that work Hawaii when Hawaii
was significantly poorer was able to
build all this infrastructure but now
that government spends much more money
it's going bad this supports my argument
that government usually makes things
worse government is taking our taxpayer
dollars and this is why I've made this a
central point of my campaign because we
all pay taxes where are those taxpayer
dollars going the majority of those
dollars are not going towards serving
those very real needs that we have
instead they're going to wage these
wasteful wars that have nothing to do
with the national security interests of
our country the interests of our troops
the interests of our people which is
which is a central issue and you know I
I'm often asked by reporters and
Washington oh gosh okay fine you're
talking about foreign policy what about
all the other issues that the American
people are really concerned about but
unless we deal with this central issue
of where our taxpayer dollars are going
in the cost of war we can't begin to
address how we find the resources where
we come up with the money to be able to
pay for these other things now you would
still have a military you wouldn't yes
totally
cut it out how much would it be cut how
much would be left I don't think it's an
arbitrary number I think once again
focus on what is our objective our
objective must be to have a strong and
ready capable military able to fulfill
their mission of protecting and
defending our country and the American
people now we've got troops who are
deployed in so many countries around the
world but the questions that that aren't
really countries that aren't really
asked even in the Armed Services
Committee where I serve or answered is
well how many of those bases how many of
those countries actually require
prolonged US president a presence to
serve our interests so what happens in
the committee in a sec well here's
here's the issue is when we talk about
this this fearful word called brac base
realignment and closing right people
actually vote against that commission
from doing their job which is to look at
these bases around the world and here at
home and say hey do we still need them
are they still performing a necessary
function for our national security and
if not let's repurpose them or shut them
down we should explain this to viewers
who don't know what brac is it was
created because you would try to the
military wanted to close some bases but
that cold Congresspersons or not my base
that's right so they then said we'll
create this create a mission exactly
create a commission who will be the
neutral arbiters the member of Congress
won't take the heat they'll say well hey
this commission is the one that decided
this but still the member of Congress
fights against what that Commission has
recommended rather once again than
looking at this from an objective
perspective of being responsible
caretakers for the taxpayer dollar and
looking at what is actually necessary
for our military to be able to do the
job of protecting and defending our
country so I think there's a huge
opportunity to reduce defense spending
in that area there's a huge opportunity
to reduce defense spending in this arms
race that I'm talking about this arms
race that is making our country in the
world less safe in de-escalating these
tensions with nuclear-armed countries so
that we are moving closer to that future
that both JFK and President Reagan were
looking towards where our people that
people who live on this planet don't
have to live in fear of nuclear
catastrophe coming at any moment you
would reduce the military spending spend
it domestically but let's fight about
that you want Medicare for all I want to
see Medicare choice so right now we as
people we're spending far more on health
care than any other developed country in
the world because we invent the best new
stuff well I would argue that our big
insurance companies and big
pharmaceutical companies get far greater
profits from us than they do in other
countries we pay far more our people pay
far more for insulin for example here in
this country than they do across the
border in Canada or even in Mexico same
product same safety qualifications but
we pay way more I met a mother the other
day whose daughter was diagnosed with
juvenile diabetes and they can't afford
health insurance they can't afford it it
would be thousands of dollars every
month for their family and they can't
afford the $300 per vial of insulin that
her daughter needs here so they go to
Mexico and they buy a whole lot of
insulin for 30 bucks a vial just across
the border that's just one example of
many how the crony capitalists culture
that we have is making these profits for
big insurance and big pharma rather than
saying hey how can we as a country
ensure that the American people are
getting quality health care and by
having this Medicare choice plan where
you've got every single person they're
able to get that quality healthcare
medical choice
the private I've never advocated for
that but you signed on to the bill and
that's what the bill said the bill the
bill doesn't expressly eliminate private
insurance I agree with the the concept
of Medicare for all what I would call
Medicare choice because it provides for
that lower-cost quality health care for
every American regardless of how little
you may have in your pocket but also
allowing for those who you know if you
want to keep your employer-sponsored
health care plan or if you've got a
union that's negotiated a great health
care plan or if you just as a private
citizen you would rather pay into a
private complementary plan or otherwise
it should have the freedom to do so and
we can afford this Bernie Sanders who
promotes it admits it will cost three
trillion dollars we are already paying
more and I think that's the point that's
often missed we are already paying more
so if we are able to cut out that middle
man's profits of the big insurance
companies and the profits they're
already taking then we're able to pay
less we as taxpayers are able to pay
less if we pass the law that I've been
advocating for a long time now to allow
Medicare allow our government to
negotiate lower prescription drug prices
for the American people
we bring down those costs we don't allow
them to continue to get price gouge
people we reform our patent laws that
make it so these prescription drug
companies can't exploit the system as
they are where you know they'll get the
patent for a certain number of years
they then tweak it and try to block the
generic companies from being able to
sell that drug at lower prices we make
these necessary reforms to bring down
the cost overall for everyone while
ensuring that they're still able to get
that quality health care but one upside
of those patent laws which do make the
drugs cost more is that the cool new
drugs that we all want are invented here
that insulin you talked about it's
probably invented here because the
government makes you pay about a billion
dollars to get through the FDA you have
to make a huge profit to bring us better
thing here's the thing with it with the
insulin example and I think this is
emblematic of the problems that were
with what the prescription drug
companies by and large are doing is that
the scientists who created insulin they
sold that patent for a dollar for one
dollar and we look at how much insulin
is costing families whose loved ones
whether it's their children or their
parents who depend on that insulin to
stay alive and how they are struggling
just to be able to afford it and the
price gouging that's taking place this
is what I'm talking about the crony
capitalism that I think needs to change
we've got to focus on how we can best
serve and support the American people
how we can best empower small businesses
how we can strengthen our economy we
don't do this by continuing to enable
whether it's subsidies or this kind of
exploitation to occur and by cutting
unnecessary military spending we can
afford this by bringing down our defense
spending by ending these wasteful wars
the new cold war an arms race we're
bringing back a lot of resources that
would otherwise continue to be spent
there with healthcare we're reducing the
cost and this is this is the key
component of this we're already paying
for this one way or the other except
right now you know I get I get a certain
chunk of money taken out of my paycheck
every month that goes to Blue Cross Blue
Shield for the insurance for my family
instead of that amount of money going to
Blue Cross Blue Shield then I that
amount of money would instead be going
to a Medicare choice plan except it
would be less but much as I would like
to cut the military I don't see how you
can get the money because the military
entire budget is 700 billion and that's
a long way from three trillion it's
actually more it's actually more I mean
700 billion is is the direct amount of
the annual oh it's around seven hundred
billion every year that goes to the
Department of Defense but that does not
include the hundreds of millions of
dollars that go towards the the slush
fund the OCO fund the overseas
contingency operations fund which has no
constraints on how the Department of
Defense is spending those dollars those
are not accounted for within that budget
all right well
add a hundred billion or two hundred
billion it comes nowhere close to what
you and your fellow Democrats want to
spend free college Medicare for all we
can't afford this stuff it's just silly
the the money that we are going to save
by ending these wasteful wars you're
right it won't cover every other thing
that we need to accomplish we've got to
look at every goal that we have every
objective that we have every need that
the American people have to see here's
the resources that we have how can we
best use them to serve the interests of
the American people yeah sure I think
there will need to be some reforms to
the tax code to make it so that it's
more fair to make it so that companies
like Amazon are not walking away
scot-free paying zero taxes and also
getting over a hundred million dollars
in a tax credit while small business
owners are struggling just to be able to
pay their taxes and take care of their
employees and earn a living in the
process this is a bigger issue that we
have to look at across every sector of
our economy and in every way that the
American people need to see these
services improve for them free college
don't you think college has already
wasted a lot of money they do absolutely
and that's why I think I think those who
are talking about free college and I
think that we do need to make sure that
our students our young people are
getting opportunity whether it's for
vocational training apprenticeships
college community college there's a lot
of opportunities there for people to get
the skills that they need but in order
to do this we have to address the
overarching issue which is why is it
costing more and more and more every
single year just throwing what it'll
cost wait it's free well this is the
problem is just throwing more money at
it isn't going to solve it so we have to
deal with the systemic problem here the
root cause of the problem one of which
is look I spoke with the college
professor recently about this issue and
he said you wanna you want to see why
it's costing more and more why don't you
look at how much administrators of a lot
of these colleges are being paid or
overpaid let's actually see where these
dollars are going let's look at the fact
that these universities many of them
don't have any kind of accountability or
transparency to say hey
look you know our students graduate you
know 90% of them are able to go and get
a good-paying job in the field of their
choosing or the field of their training
versus another that might have it be
like 10% or 20% you don't have this kind
of accountability in place well you have
it if you make it free if the student
had some skin in the game his own money
oh my I care about how many
administrators there are but what we're
working on it and we'll be releasing
this in detail in the course of our
campaign is taking a comprehensive
approach to this in how we're looking at
education beyond high school both
looking at this overall cost having
accountability and transparency there by
looking at how we leverage technology to
bring down the cost of education and how
we can best provide these opportunities
to those who are seeking skills I'll use
myself as an example I started my
bachelor's degree later on in life I was
working full time and I actually
continued it while I was deployed on
both of my deployments you know we had
an education tent in our camp in Iraq
and and I went and I did classes in that
tent online you know mortar attacks were
coming in I'd have to run out and go
into the bunker but I was able to to
fulfill those credits there while doing
that but also I was able to take tests I
tested out of probably somewhere between
40 and 60 credits because I took the
test I already had the knowledge didn't
have to take the class cheaper a lot
cheaper so there are a lot of things
that are available to bring down the
cost of education that really are never
talked about or discussed and I think
that's at the heart of how we tackle
what is a difficult challenge of my
generation which is this heavy student
debt burden one last thing to fight
about the $15 minimum wage yeah how does
that not destroy opportunity for a 17
year old in his first job who isn't
worth $15 an hour well I think we got a
look at how inflation has raised the
cost of living
raise the cost alone
minimum wage know what it is it is and
and our federal minimum wage has not
increased along with inflation I think
that's what we're trying to balance out
here how a living wage which is
different you know here in New York City
and in a state like Hawaii and San
Francisco or Los Angeles cost of living
is much higher and no one what the DOE
only one minimum wage for the con I
think it's this I think it's a starting
point and I think that in other places
$15 is higher than what a living wage in
that place would be required so I think
we're looking at this as an investment
in people the labor the people who are
really the fuel and the engine that make
our economy grow why is it the
government's business you have an
employer and a worker and they make
their own deal it's pretty good now for
the workers because they have a lot of
choice unemployment slaw and every
situation is different
well I have any minimum wage because
we've seen unfortunately through
different examples in our country's past
how workers have been exploited and even
though unemployment numbers are low now
if you just look at those surface
numbers what those numbers don't reflect
is that very often you have people who
are working two full-time jobs just to
be able to keep a roof over their heads
because one full-time just one full-time
job doesn't cut it and I think this is
what we're seeking horror richer now
than they were so if they're working to
live as they wanted more specific
adjusted for the cost of living even the
poor if you look at the numbers of how
many people in this country are living
paycheck to paycheck people who are
struggling who are struggling and with
that one emergency whether it's a
child's visit to the emergency room or
an unexpected expense that they have to
cover they don't know if they're gonna
be able to make the next month's rent
it's terrible voices say you can't have
any job because McDonald's is gonna
automate rather than pay fees that's a
whole that's a whole new challenge and I
think I think you know businesses want
to know I think businesses are looking
at automation not because we're trying
to pass
$15 minimum wage but because they're
trying to look at how they can make
their businesses run more efficiently
right now they can identify by your
higher wage no I think the automation
revolution was coming regardless of that
and that's that's a different bigger
challenge that we need to recognize both
with the challenges it presents but also
the opportunities that you know if
you're going in to Taco Bell and you're
going and punching in your order on a
computer rather than standing at the
cash register then perhaps you're
freeing up that labor to do other jobs
that only a person can do so I think
there's challenge and opportunity here I
think there is potential I'm looking
more into a universal basic income
option to be able to help deal both with
this automation revolution and the
challenge is not giving every person
regardless a certain amount of money
there are different models and this is
I'm looking at different models of how
this could work where it has worked and
and importantly how do you pay for it
you've never run a business you've never
had to deal with hiring workers and
having to pay minimum wage you've always
been in politics so many of you
politicians have never run a business
your father was a politician well let me
let me stop you right there because I
grew up in my parents are teachers by
trade and training and we grew up in our
families small business my parents
started a restaurant and all five of us
just all five of us kids you know it
took turns sweeping floors wiping tables
and serving food and and experienced the
challenges and the hardships and also
the rewards of a family-run business
I appreciate that that our small
businesses are the backbone of our
economy they are the number one employer
of people in this country and I think
that's one of the things that we need to
correct within our federal policies is
how currently whether you're looking at
tax code trade policy our overall
economic policy they overarching lis
benefit the biggest corporations who can
afford to pay for those lobbyists to
come and say hey you know you've got to
change the the language in this bill or
built to benefit this massive
corporation where as small business
owners they can't afford lobbyists they
don't have time to think about well
who's advocating for us in Washington as
a result they don't have a voice they
can't afford the compliance officers to
understand other exactly another major
issue and this is something that I will
correct as president given the
background that my family comes from the
experience that we've had going through
that together and recognizing how
important it is that we are empowering
these amazing people who are working
hard every day to create these jobs for
our economy I apologize for not knowing
you it's all right family restaurant I'm
glad we can have a civil argument about
some of these areas where we disagree a
few politicians want to do that anymore
isn't it of all the people polling over
a percent you're the only one who so far
has come and sat down to talk this is a
problem that we're seeing in our
political culture today is where people
are increasingly unwilling on creasing
ly unwilling to sit down with those who
may be quote-unquote on the other team
even for those who are asking to lead
our country and I think this is how we
move forward together this is the kind
of campaign that we're building the kind
of leadership that I bring we're already
we're seeing Democrats Republicans
independents libertarians showing
support coming out to our town house
joining our campaign saying look I love
my country you love our country let's
come together as Americans with
appreciation for our Constitution our
freedoms civil liberties and rights and
have this civil discourse and dialogue
about how we can move forward together
that would be good thank you very much
thank you